dans le cadre de la table ronde sur
l'économie circulaire dans le secteur du
bâtiment qui nourrit réunit ce matin
nous accueillons Monsieur Jacques
Vernier président de la commission des
filières de responsabilité élargie des
producteurs
madame Yolaine officiel membre du
Conseil national de l'Ordre des
architectes Monsieur Franck Perrault
président du Conseil des professions de
la Fédération française du bâtiment
je salue la présidente du groupe
d'études économie circulaire notre
collègue Martha de Sidrac ainsi que
l'ensemble des membres de ce groupe
d'études qui nous ont opportunément
proposé la tenue de cette table ronde
qui permettra notamment
un autre commission de tirer un bilan de
la loi relative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et à l'économie circulaire je
vais prendre celui-là parce que celui-là
promulgué en février 2000 et dites loi
Ajac
[Musique]
alors Jean de 15% du total des déchets
produits en France le secteur du
bâtiment est après celui des travaux
publics une des principales sources de
déchets dans notre pays
ce secteur occupe à ce titre une place
stratégique dans notre politique
d'économie circulaire depuis la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015 le
bâtiment et les travaux publics font
ainsi l'objet de cibles spécifiques
d'une part ce secteur est identifié par
la loi comme contributeur à l'objectif
de réduction de 5% des quantités de
déchets d'activités économiques en 2030
par rapport à 2010 d'autre part est
surtout le législateur de 2015 avait
prévu une valorisation sous forme de
matière de 70% des déchets du bâtiment
et des travaux publics en 2020 selon les
travaux préparatoires de la loi Ajac le
taux de valorisation matière des déchets
du secteur du bâtiment n'atteignait
pourtant que 54% 2019 soit 16 points de
moins que l'objectif qui lui était
assigné
rappelons que cette trop faible
valorisation des matières et des déchets
du bâtiment et dommageables d'un point
de vue environnemental et économique on
peut notamment évoquer la double
pression foncière exercée par cette
déchets en aval car il contribue à la
saturation des sites de stockage en
amont car l'absence de circularité
induit l'ouverture de nouveaux sites
d'extraction de matériaux il faut
également rappeler que le bilan carbone
associé à certains matériaux neufs la
seule production de ciment génère 7% des
émissions mondiales de dioxine de
carbone CO2
autre élément de contexte il y avait
nourri les travaux préparatoires de la
loi Haget la multiplication des dépôts
sauvages alimentés notamment par les
déchets du bâtiment pour répondre à ces
défis plusieurs solutions ont été
apportées par la loi ajecte
le principal levier est évidemment la
mise en place d'une filière de
responsabilité élargie du producteur
pour les produits et les matériaux de
construction du secteur du bâtiment
je rappelle les quelques missions que le
législateur a confié aux éco-organismes
en charge de l'organisation de cette
filière REP le développement du réemploi
de la réutilisation et du recyclage de
ces déchets par l'instauration
d'objectifs contraignants inscrit dans
le cahier des charges des échos
organismes le principe d'une reprise
sans frais de ces déchets lorsqu'ils
font l'objet d'une collecte séparée
l'instauration d'un maillage territorial
des points de collecte afin que chaque
artisan soit en mesure de trouver à
proximité une solution de reprise de ces
déchets parmi les autres mesures
introduites par la loi GEC affectant
directement le secteur du bâtiment on
peut également en citer l'amélioration
du diagnostic déchet et notamment son
extension aux opérations de démolition
ou de réhabilitation significative ou
encore l'amélioration de la traçabilité
des déchets du bâtiment dans les devis
de construction et les devis de
démolition
malheureusement la mise en oeuvre de ces
avancées prend du retard la date
d'entrée en vigueur de la filière REP
fixée par le législateur au 1er janvier
2022 par exemple été repoussé au 1er
janvier 2023 les pouvoirs publics ont
justifié sur retard par la crise
sanitaire et la situation actuelle de
tension sur l'approvisionnement pour
certaines matières de première de
construction des motifs qui aussi
légitimes soient-ils ne doivent pas
cacher la lenteur initiale des travaux
préparatoires
notre commission est consciente des
difficultés inhérentes au lancement de
ce qui est amené à devenir la plus
grande filière REP toutefois la filière
devant son construire en avançant on ne
peut continuellement reculer pour mieux
sauter cette table ronde doit donc nous
permettre de faire un bilan d'étape de
la mise en oeuvre de la loi GEC et des
difficultés d'application qui persistent
j'espère qu'elle ouvrira également des
perspectives en matière de réemploi en
matière de réutilisation notamment
nous devons et nous pouvons faire
beaucoup mieux dans un contexte
géopolitique qui nous pousse à réduire
notre dépendance à certaines matières
premières
monsieur Vernier je vous aide la parole
et sénateur
oui donc je suis président de la
commission dite interfelliaire des de
responsabilités élargi les producteurs
vous savez qui il existait jusqu'à la
loi Haget une douzaine de filières la
première historiquement avait été celle
des emballages il y a une trentaine
d'années et puis petit à petit ça s'est
étendu au textile aux meubles aux
déchets électriques etc etc la loi à
Jacques a rajouté d'ailleurs une dizaine
de filières REP supplémentaires aux 12
qui préexister et parmi cette dizaine il
y a donc la répartiment
bâtiment qui donc va obliger comme
toutes les filières rép aux producteurs
de matériaux de construction de prendre
en charge et une fine et les déchets qui
résultent soit de la construction soit
de la démolition de prendre en charge
techniquement et financièrement c'est ça
la notion de responsabilité et l'argile
des producteurs et l'argile à la fin de
vie des produits
c'est très effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président elle
est importante elle est importante
d'abord quantitativement puisque je
crois que vous l'avez dit
quantitativement le volume des déchets
du bâtiment un peu plus de 40 millions
de tonnes est égal à lui seul à la
totalité de nos déchets ménagers on a à
peu près un peu plus de 40 millions de
tonnes de déchets ménagers en France et
on a 42 45 enfin les estimations varient
un peu million de tonnes à l'échelle du
bâtiment donc c'est quelque c'est une
grosse affaire quantitativement et
qualitativement c'est aussi une affaire
importante parce que certains ah oui je
précise quand je dis déchets du bâtiment
45 millions de tonnes je dis bien à
déchets du bâtiment pas du BTP pas du
BTP du bâtiment pas des travaux publics
ok non ça c'est important travaux
publics on a beaucoup plus voilà donc
qualitativement c'est aussi une affaire
importante
parce que
la le destin actuel des déchets du
bâtiment
né
pas très n'est pas très correct certains
déchets du bâtiment se collecte et se
recycle bien c'est le cas notamment des
métaux les métaux d'ailleurs dans toutes
les filières se recyclent bien parce que
on trouve toujours un bon destin soit à
l'acier soit à l'aluminium recycler donc
pour les métaux pas de souci recyclé à
90% actuellement
quand on descend au bois c'est déjà
beaucoup moins bon c'est inférieur à
50%. et quand on descend à d'autres
matériaux comme le plastique comme le
plâtre dans le bâtiment et même comme le
verre on descend à des taux de recyclage
qui sont inférieurs à 20% et même à 5%
pour le verre
donc on voit que
la situation est inégale pour les
matériaux mais que en dehors des métaux
en dehors des métaux le destin des
matériaux du bâtiment n'est pas bon
alors l'idée l'idée c'est de pour mieux
collecter tous ces déchets du bâtiment
qui pour certains d'entre eux comme l'a
dit le président vont dans des décharges
sauvages il y a pas que le déchets du
bâtiment dans les déchets sauvages ne
faites pas dire que je n'ai pas dit il
n'y a pas que ça mais il y a des déchets
du bâtiment dans les décharges il y en a
mais il n'y a pas que ça pour donc
donner une un destin
honorable à tous nos déchets du bâtiment
l'idée fondamentale de cette règle du
bâtiment et que soit mise en place vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président un
réseau maillé de point de reprise pour
tous les déchets du client un réseau
maillet dense c'est à dire que l'idée
est que toute détenteur de l'échelle du
bâtiment tout artisan et sauve dans
certaines zones un point de reprise à
moins de 10 km de chez lui de telle
façon que le temps pour y accéder
soit le
le moindre possible donc un réseau moyen
dense à l'échelle nationale ça ferait
entre 5000 et 10000 points de reprise et
deuxièmement dans ces points de reprise
pour peu que les déchets aient été quand
même prêtablement un peu triés pour peu
qu'ils aient été trié dans ses points de
reprise les déchets du bâtiment seront
accueillis sans frais sans frais alors
qu'aujourd'hui quand un détenteur quand
une entreprise qui est détient des
déchets du bâtiment veut les confier à
une déchetterie professionnelle etc
évidemment il doit payer il doit payer
pour accueillir ces déchets donc reprise
sans frais
reprise sans frais ces points de reprise
ce réseau moyen de points de reprise
plusieurs milliers en France seraient
quoi en pratique soit des déchetteries
publiques pour les collectivités qui le
souhaiteront rien n'est obligatoire pour
elle donc c'est facultatif si elle le
souhaite elles accueillent seuls pas
elles veulent pas
ça peut être des déchetteries
professionnelles dédiées aux déchets du
bâtiment et troisièmement ça peut être
des points de reprise chez les
distributeurs de matériaux de
construction car la loi oblige les
construction en tout cas au-delà d'une
certaine surface de vente à avoir aussi
un point de reprise des déchets par de
verre
dernière chose dernière information et
je m’entendrai là dans ces points dans
ces points de reprise dans tous les
points de reprise du réseau maillet tous
les déchets tous les déchets doivent
être accueillis ça peut être le ciment
ça peut être béton ça peut être le bois
ça peut être le plâtre de telle façon de
telle façon qu'un artisan qu'un
détenteur n'est pas à aller dans un
point pour s'il s'agit de gravats dans
un autre point s'il s'agit de bois etc
donc le principe même du réseau maillet
c'est tous les déchets doivent y être
je m'en tiendrai là si vous voulez bien
oui je terminerai en disant que les
producteurs donc qui ont cette
responsabilité élargée comme vous le
savez la plupart
délègue cette responsabilité à des
éco-organismes à des éco-organismes
alors qu'il est donc
début octobre
4 éco-organismes ont été agréés par
l'État 4
soit uniquement pour les déchets inertes
genre ciment tuile béton etc
soit aussi un effort organisme pouvait
se faire agréer pour les autres types de
déchets c'est à dire le métal le bois le
plâtre le plastique etc bon en tout cas
quatre écorces ont été agréés à cette
date pour prendre en charge cette
filière de responsabilité élargie des
producteurs voilà je vais m'en tenir là
pour l'instant si vous voulez bien merci
monsieur le Président pour ce propos
liminaire je vais donner la parole à
mesdames officiers
vous avez la parole
merci
bonjour mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs les sénatrices donc fiché moi
je suis architecte
fondatrice et gérante d'une SARL
d'architecture et je suis également élue
au Conseil national de l'Ordre des
architectes
les élus les élus régionaux et nationaux
nous sommes 300 en France nous avons
alors des dernières élections
présidentielles et législatives
travaillées à l'écriture d'un plaidoyer
autour de l'architecture comme solution
de l'habitat de nos villes et des
territoires je vous le montre ce
plaidoyer j'en ai pas d'exemplaires pour
vous mais vous pouvez le télécharger sur
le site de l'Ordre des architectes donc
sur
architectes.org je vous invite à le
télécharger parce qu'au travers de ce
plaidoyer nous avons formulé cinq axes
de proposition autour
de l'urgence climatique face à laquelle
nous sommes et des besoins de changement
de paradigme auquel nous devons faire
face
en préambule je dirais que le meilleur
déchet est celui qu'on ne produit pas
avant de le gérer si on ne le produit
pas c'est peut-être la meilleure réponse
que nous pouvons apporter et nous
architecte auprès de nos maîtres
d'ouvrage et des entreprises nous devons
travailler dès la conception à savoir
comment est-ce qu'on va réaliser une
architecture sobre et frugale
on pourrait partir du 1er constat qui
est de dire que la ville existe déjà et
que le premier déchet qu'on ne doit pas
produire et bien celui des bâtiments
existants
en ce sens que finalement on a un
patrimoine bâti qui est là avec un
certain nombre de vacances qu'il faut
regarder de près et peut-être qu'un des
premiers enjeux est de regarder ce qui
existe et de travailler pour pouvoir le
réhabiliter
le réutiliser retrouver de nouveaux
usages de manière à faire en sorte que
se mettre carré construit ne soit pas un
déchet plus tard
par ailleurs en ce qui concerne
l'utilisation des matériaux évidemment
je parlais de des co-conception tout à
l'heure la réflexion doit porter sur la
manière dont on utilise des matériaux
qui probablement viennent de la matière
terre et donc les matériaux biosourcés
et géosourcés qui demandent notamment
moins de matière de transformation et
qui sont renouvelables de même
puisqu'ils proviennent de la terre je
pense par exemple au matériau type terre
bois paille chanvre voilà qui sont des
matériaux qui peuvent être utilisés et
qui sont facilement
aussi compostable en fin de vie parce
que l'enjeu c'est aussi d'analyser le
matériau sur l'ensemble de sa vie et de
savoir ce qui va donner à la fin pour
éviter de gérer un déchet supplémentaire
et donc on parle de l'architecture du
circuit court et de l'architecture des
100 km et puis enfin il y a la question
du réemploi des matériaux alors il y a
de nombreuses voix qu'il faut évidemment
observer sur la traçabilité des
matériaux mais peut-être déjà sur le
diagnostic de ce qui existe déjà
quand l'objectif est de peut-être
démolir finalement parce qu'on n'a pas
trouvé d'autres solutions un bâtiment
c'est de référencer de démonter et de et
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
réemployer ces matériaux cela implique
évidemment une gestion de ce nouveau
circuit qui est la traçabilité de ces
matériaux les stockages les filières qui
puissent permettre de redistribuer ces
matières
aux différents aux différentes
entreprises et de aussi connaître les
différentes sources qui existent alors
il y a un certain nombre de belles
initiatives qui existent déjà par des
sites Internet qui référence
ces matières à réemployer mais il faut
les développer et que ce soit beaucoup
plus large que ce qu'on connaît déjà
aujourd'hui qui reste à une initiative
vraiment de petit échelle
et enfin
en ce qui concerne la conception
peut-être que je dirais que le but nous
dès lors dès la phase de conception du
projet que ce soit en rénovation ou en
construction c'est peut-être de penser à
la démontabilité et donc la sobriété
dans la manière dont on va mettre en
oeuvre les matériaux je vous donne un
exemple tout simple c'est beaucoup plus
facile de démonter une plainte quand
elle est vissée que quand elle est
collée ou clouée
et ce petit exemple en fait ce doit se
généraliser à l'échelle du bâtiment pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que nos bâtiments
soient démontables pour être mieux
réemployés réutiliser
voilà il y a plein d'autres
idées à développer et je répondrai plus
tard à vos questions bien évidemment
merci merci Monsieur Franck Perrot vous
avez la parole
bonjour Monsieur Madame les sénateurs
essénatrices merci pour votre invitation
donc peut-être juste un chiffre pour
appeler un petit peu déjà le secteur du
bâtiment donc là FFV c'est 50000
entreprises dont 35 000 artisans
ces deux tiers c'est quand même 150
milliards aujourd'hui de chiffre
d'affaires le bâtiment bien sûr sans les
travaux publics et représente également
les deux tiers des 1 million 250 000
salariés donc salariés donc hors
dirigeons et or intérim donc nous on se
félicite de la de la mise en place de
l'emplace mise en place de cette règle
il faut savoir qu'elle a fait la source
du bâtiment on travaille depuis 92 ans
sur les déchets puis il y a eu 2000 et
c'est vraiment un sujet très important
pour nous qui s'est beaucoup accéléré
lors de ces dernières années avec
notamment on en a parlé la nécessité du
remploi l'utilisation bio sourcée on a
vu qu'avec les revints les industriels
ont fait des on fait des progrès
spectaculaires on pensait pas qu'on
pouvait
les habitudes et puis également la on
travaille beaucoup également sur la
tablette des bâtiments comme on l'a
évoqué qu'un bâtiment puisse avoir une
seconde vie et qui puisse accompagner
les citoyens tout au long de leur vie
donc au sujet de la au sujet de la reine
donc ce qui est important pour nous
c'est bien sur le développement du tri
on en a parlé donc je reviens je
reviendrai dessus après le remploi et la
réduction des dépôts sauvages qui pour
nous sont une vérité table concurrence
déloyale puisque souvent ce sont les
entreprises les mois vertueuses qui font
cela
on a fait un énorme travail qui a été
fait durant cette année donc merci
d'avoir prolongé d'un an ça nous a
permis d'échanger énormément alors c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile le nom Verdier
l'a rappelé c'est ne foi le volume de
toute traite on parle de 45 millions de
déchets et peut-être un prix en ordre de
croisière la raie va générer ça va être
2,7 milliards d'euros qui vont aller
s'alléger cours gagniste pour faciliter
le le tri des déchets
voilà donc aujourd'hui on se félicite
parce qu'il y a une certaine on a
demandé qu'une certaine progressivité
notamment au niveau au niveau tarifaire
et puis la mise en place qui doit se
faire progressivement néanmoins on a
écrit donc à deux fois avec l'ensemble
de la filière à la première ministre de
filaire bâtiment je parle avec nous nos
collègues de la CAPEB avec évidemment
les parties TP qui sont concernées par
l'arrêt voilà donc on a on quelques
quelques inquiétudes aujourd'hui la
première et on était hier donc direction
avec au ministère de l'écologie la
première je crois qu'il faut bien
comprendre que l'arrêt va démarrer mais
pour le moment rien encore été
contractualisé avec les déchetteries
donc là si je fais un message à passer à
vous élu c'est qu'il faut pas on a déjà
certains secteurs ou les déchetteries
publiques arrêtent de reprendre les
déchets du bâtiment et ça c'est
catastrophique parce qu'aujourd'hui donc
c'est très bête mais en application 1er
janvier mais pour le moment on n'a pas
de solution je vais dire c'est en train
de s'organiser on nous l'a bien dit
c'est clair les écoles ils viennent
d'être nommé ils ont pas encore
contractualisé avec les déchetteries et
comme l'a dit prénom Verdier que ça soit
que ça soit public que ça soit privé
mais que ça soit également dans les
points de distribution donc tout ça va
se mettre en place va se mettre en place
progressivement la deuxième chose
également on a beaucoup communiqué
depuis deux ans pour vraiment que
l'ensemble des entrepreneurs se sentent
concernés par cette reprise des déchets
et par le tri pour nous c'est essentiel
donc on leur bien expliqué qu'en fait ce
qu'on les pays en amont ensuite sur une
reprise gratuite en face et donc pour
eux c'était quand même c'était quand
même important donc on les a on les a
embarqués et aujourd'hui il faut savoir
par exemple qu'on a toujours pas les
conditions de tri pour une reprise
gratuite on entend beaucoup de choses
donc c'est vrai que juste être nommé les
coordonnées on va dire chapeau qui doit
coordonner tout ça en emportant pas les
éléments et on entend divers choses par
exemple une benne à vitrage si un
vitrage et fissuré elle sera pas reprise
gratuitement on sait toujours pas si une
plaque de plâtre à partir du moment où
elle a une tapisserie collée dessus
est-ce qu'elle sera repris gratuitement
voilà donc on a beaucoup d'incertitudes
également à ce sujet là et il faut très
rapidement qu'on ait un éclaircissement
sur sur ce point
on demande également leur Auton autant
on est tout à fait prêt et on veut que
cette trappe démarre au 1er janvier
autant en un vrai problème au niveau du
prix puisqu'on a eu les on a vu les
premiers tarifs divulgués au mois de
novembre avec des grosses différences de
tarifs selon les écorces et
malheureusement vous savez que lorsque
l'on fait un devis en général alors pour
les plus en train pour les plus petites
entreprises c'est à 3-4 mois mais sur
des chantiers importants c'est des
chantiers qui vont arriver dans 9 mois
12 mois 15 mois donc on demande
premièrement un report de pour nous de
du paiement c'était co contribution bien
qu'elle doit démarrer ou tout du moins
la minimiser mais surtout ce qu'on
demande et c'est plus important c'est
que pour la suite parce que l'on sait
que pour le moment c'est un prix
relativement faible on a bien été écouté
on remercie les écorialistes mais très
vite elle va monter en puissance on
parle d'un avec multiplié par 4 ou 5 et
donc il faut à tout prix qu'on ait les
tarifs des années N+1 au moins 9 mois
avant pour pouvoir les réintégrer dans
dans nos prix puisque puisque si vous
voulez il y aura il y aura un moment il
faut bien comprendre que dans certains
métiers comme l'avait dit comme l'a dit
pour le moment la reprise est
pratiquement déjà gratuite sur les
matériaux etc ces entreprises vont payer
des coûts contributions pour l'ensemble
de la filière mais ce qui est bien il
faut tous mettre en commun mais donc
faire attention il va avoir des défenses
de prix il faut à tout prix qu'on puisse
les répercuter dans dans nos devis et la
reprise gratuite comme je vous le disais
dans certains plans de métiers bat loin
de compenser l'éco contributions qu'on
aura que l'on aura à payer
on a on a également donc je vous ai
parlé du tri je vous ai parlé de la mise
en place des déchetteries et on a un
sujet un peu plus technique qui qui nous
inquiète et c'est vraiment un des sujets
le prix et ça qui nous inquiète c'est
quelle est la définition du producteur
nous avions compris au début des textes
qu'en fait c'était nos industriels
qui étaient qui étaient considéré comme
émetteurs sur le marché comme c'est
l'ensemble de l'ensemble des rêves
lorsqu'on va acheter du une plaque de
placo lorsqu'on va acheter une barre
d'aluminium nous allons payer à notre à
notre industriel une un montant fait
pour trier les déchets et qu'ensuite
donc on aura une reprise gratuite et
aujourd'hui nous avons certains métiers
où on a un peu où il y a eu des
différences de point de vue donc c'est
vraiment le débat du jour c'est ce qui
doit être considéré comme émetteur sur
le marché puisque notamment pour les
charpentiers bois pour les menuisiers
bois pour les métalliers pour les
charpentiers métalliques on demande que
ça soit les entreprises en fait
qui soit considéré comme émetteur sur le
marché alors au-delà du prix peu importe
que ça soit bon c'est énormément
énormément de travail pour les faut voir
des petits artisans qui sont quatre ou
cinq ça va te donner ça va donner un
poids administratif qui va être hyper
important donc nous on demande vraiment
on comprend pas l'ensemble des autres
êtres c'est vraiment le plus en amont
possible et là on redescend en redescend
en aval pour certains métiers on a
extrêmement peur pour des pour des on va
te prendre une porte une porte en bois
une charpente en bois qu'en fait ça
décourage le plus le poids administratif
des courage nos artisans de continuer à
fabriquer et donc d'acheter des produits
tout fait parce qu'elles pourront pas
avoir cette charge administrative ce que
je pourrais dire pour finir c'est que on
croit énormément sur le réemploi on est
très actif à ce niveau là on travaille
beaucoup sur un des gros problèmes dure
emploi c'est la surabilité donc on
travaille énormément pour que c'est pour
ces pour ces matériaux de réemploi
puissent à puisse être puisse être
ensuite assuré parce que pour le moment
c'est pas le cas donc ça comprennent
notamment la filière et puis également
compte également beaucoup sur nos
industriels comme vous comme vous l'avez
comme vous l'avez évoqué mais un peu
fiché sur le en fait sur le à partir du
moment où ils sont responsables de ces
déchets qu'on va mettre en œuvre sur une
éco-conception beaucoup plus vertueuse
je vous dis on a su faire sur les
produits bio-sourcion doit pouvoir le
faire également aujourd'hui et et que
l'on puisse commander uniquement les
matériaux dont on a besoin parce que
très souvent on a plus de matériaux on a
plus de choses et donc comme on disait
c'est les meilleurs déchets c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on ne produit pas voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire puis je suis
prêt bien sûr répondre à votre question
et je vous remercie
bien merci monsieur perroche je vais
donner la parole à la présidente partage
de Sidrac
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame messieurs
les d'ores et déjà pour vos propres
liminaires et un certain nombre de
questions que vous soulevez et auquel
j'espère que ces tableaux nous permettra
de nous éclairer si on n'arrive pas à
voir toutes les réponses instantanément
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
Longeau mais vous-même aussi monsieur
Vernier les quatre ergones et
éco-organismes qui ont été agréés et
communéros et comaisons valdélia et
valobat qui donc
doit se mettre maintenant je dirais en
fonctionnement et ont été agréés pour la
filière et bâtiment qui doit rentrer en
vigueur je le rappelle au 1er janvier
2023 donc demain en fait c'est c'est
tout c'est un imminent et même si on ne
peut que regretter le retard d'un an par
rapport à la date qui avait été fixée
par le Parlement on ne peut que se
réjouir de voir l'axe de réforme le plus
ambitieux de la loi GEC de venir enfin
réalité pour accompagner le démarrage de
la filière le gouvernement a annoncé
lors des Assises du BTP du 22 septembre
dernier une période de tolérance
jusqu'au 30 avril 2023 pour la mise en
conformité des petites entreprises
concernées par la Rep et une démarche de
sensibilisation pédagogique à cette
nouvelle obligation
l'accompagnement des acteurs vous
semble-t-elle suffisante c'est ma
première question faut-il en faire plus
la matière
je note par ailleurs que l'agrément de
plusieurs éco-organismes exauce le vœu
exprimé par le rapport de Monsieur
Vernier de 2018 d'une des grandes
concurrences au sein des filières veut
que je partage aussi personnellement à
cet égard comment envisagez-vous
l'articulation entre les différents
éco-organismes les conditions sont-elles
réunies pour qu'une concurrence saine et
efficace permettent d'améliorer les
résultats de l'ensemble de la filière
par ailleurs dispose-t-on aujourd'hui
d'une estimation du coût de la filière
rept pour l'année à venir cette question
évidemment loin d'être un Odile puisque
certains acteurs ont souhaité que le
coût de la raie autrement dit le
paiement des éco contributions vous
l'avez évoqué soit intégralement
répercuté sur le client final ce qui me
semble peu avisé en cette période
d'inflation rappelons que le principe de
la responsabilité élargie du producteur
et de faire porter la prévention et la
gestion des déchets sur l'amont et non
sur la valse c'est véritablement à ce
prix que les pratiques pourront
s'améliorer enfin comme la rappeler le
président Longeon en introduction la
question de l'économie circulaire dans
le bâtiment ne se résume pas à la mise
en place de la filière REP la loi agée
qui a prévu un autre dispositif très
intéressant qui est celui de la
planification et l'organisation des flux
de déchets du bâtiment le fameux
diagnostic déchet
les auditions que nous avons menées dans
le cadre du groupe d'études économie
circulaire du Sénat nous ont toutefois
permis d'identifier des difficultés
d'applications actuelles ou potentielles
nous regrettons tout d'abord le retard
pris dans la publication de l'arrêté
d'application cette situation était
d'autant plus d'hommageable que
l'application du diagnostic a déjà pris
du retard avec la publication tardive
des décrets six mois après la date fixée
par la loi ou en sommes-nous aujourd'hui
par ailleurs il me semble il me semble
l'absence de sanction en cas de
non-application du diagnostic pourrait
inciter les acteurs de la chaîne de
valeur à ne pas changer leur pratique
une obligation de remise d'attestation
de réalisation du diagnostic lors de la
demande de permis pour les rénovations
et démolitions pourraient constituer un
levier incitatif fort pour les acteurs
quel regard portez-vous sur cette piste
mes questions vous l'avez compris
s'adresse à vous trois donc
si vous pouviez nous éclairer ce serait
parfait je vous remercie
je vous laisse la parole dans l'ordre
que vous souhaitez
merci merci monsieur le Président bon je
vais répondre à Martin de Sidrac et
également peut-être rebondir sur ce que
disait le représentant monsieur Perrault
de la Fédération française du bâtiment
peut-être trois points parce qu'il les a
évoqué le premier point sur lequel il a
insisté et sur lequel je réinsiste c'est
la progressivité parce que bon toutes
ces filières sont quand même assez
innovantes et maintenant dans toutes les
nouvelles filières on a le souci de la
progressivité pour qu'elle soit
digérable si je puis dire et digérer par
les secteurs économiques concernés
je vais vous en donner deux exemples
le fameux réseau maillet
plusieurs milliers de points il peut pas
être créé comme ça d'un coup de baguette
magique instantanément et le les textes
prévoient que 50% du réseau maillet
devront être prêt fin 2024 donc vous
voyez on a du temps pour 50% et 100%
pour fin 2026 donc on a vraiment une
progressivité quand même assez lente de
mise en œuvre du réseau
de la même manière je ne voulais pas dit
tout à l'heure mais la loi a prévu que
la filière REP prendrait en charge des
coûts de transport le coût de transport
on a les fameux points de reprise du
réseau maillet mais on a un chantier et
il y a évidemment un transport entre le
chantier ou a lieu la construction la
démolition et le point de reprise et la
filière REP prend en charge
à terme 80% des frais de transport mais
là aussi c'est progressif parce que ça
ça va être un coup de pour la filière
REP et donc une charge pour les
producteurs et les textes disent que
dans un premier temps ce sera seulement
50% des frais de transport en 2024 puis
un ou deux ans plus tard les fameux 80%
des fréquences donc vous voyez que tout
ça est mis en oeuvre progressivement ça
s'étale sur deux trois quatre années
voilà
alors ça ça d'ailleurs une conséquence
importante c'est que du coup les écho
contributions payées par les producteurs
à la filière
eux aussi vont avoir une montée en
charge progressive c'est à dire que en
2023 qui sera la première année les éco
contributions seront relativement
faibles alors je vais vous donner un
exemple dans la plupart des barèmes ça
sera que ce soit du bois du métal du
plastique etc ça sera quelque chose
comme
2 centimes deux ou trois centimes cette
année en 2023 par kilo par kilo de
produits par kilo de produits pour une
menuiserie toute faite ça sera 60
euros pour la menuiserie toute faite
60 centimes
d'euros pour l'améliorer
donc donc progressivité de la mise en
place qui va se traduire par une montée
en charge des éco-contributions payés
par les producteurs très très lentes
également
deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur perron
c'est que il vous a dit au passage que
certes il y avait quatre éco-organismes
comme je viens de le rappeler Martha de
ce DRAC mais que il y aura un organisme
coordonnateur pour coiffer enfin pour
fédérer ces quatre accords parce que on
imagine pas que chaque économiste fasse
dans son coin son réseau aux maillé le
réseau maillet il sera commun aux quatre
éco-organismes de la même manière il y
aura un contrat type qui sera le contrat
qui sera qui lira par exemple
les écorchés collectivités locales en
cas
d'usage d'une déchetterie publique le
contrat type
entre l'écho-organismes et la
collectivité locale sera incontrative
unique unique imaginé par l'organisme
coordonnateur des quatre accords donc
voilà alors cette organisme coordinateur
est en cours de montage si je puis dire
puisque les textes disent que les quatre
écorbanismes une fois qu'ils ont été
agréés ont deux mois pour mettre en
place leur organisme coordinateur
le dernier point qui a abordé monsieur
monsieur Perrault il est il est
important effectivement il est important
pour nous tous et nous toutes c'est qui
paye des contrôles contributions le
producteur c'est qui alors
est-ce que c'est le producteur de
matériaux
le plastique de bois etc ou est-ce que
c'est le producteur de l'objet fini
pour être clair pour Hitler une partie
des professionnels du bâtiment et des
fédérations professionnelles du bâtiment
et donc c'est la thèse de la FFB je vais
la redire pour qu'elle soit bien bien
clair c'est est-ce que le menuisier qui
fabrique à façon à façon
sa fenêtre ou sa porte est-ce qu'il est
considéré comme producteur voilà alors
la FFB ne l'aurait pas souhaité en
disant non non il faut que ce soit
seulement le producteur du matériau le
producteur de bois qui perd des
coconstructions et l'État a tenu à ce
que soit le fabricants de la fenêtre
mais ça c'est un principe général c'est
un principe général parce que madame
paufischet de l'Ordre des architectes
nous a bien dit tout à l'heure que ce
qui est important c'est la façon dont le
produit est fabriqué selon qu'il est
vissé ou qu'il est collé donc on voit
bien que c'est pas seulement le matériau
qui doit être
doit contribuer etc mais que c'est
vraiment le produit car la manière dont
on leur a conçu
éco-conçue ou pas éco-conçu facilement
démontable ou pas facilement démontable
à une importance donc dans la filière
des meubles pour prendre un exemple dans
la filière des meubles qui préexistait
par rapport à la filière du bâtiment
les bénistes les bénistes qui fabriquent
lui-même son meuble il est producteur il
est petit producteur avec un barème
d'ailleurs de contribution simplifiée
très très simple mais il est producteur
voilà
alors le quatrième
et dernière question et après je
m'arrête
une question de Martin de Sidrac alors
il y avait deux questions il y avait
pourquoi le diagnostic
le
diagnostic est-il en retard bon
c'est un texte un peu difficile donc
comme tout le texte difficile ils
prennent un peu de retard
et
mais son autre question l'autre question
de Martin de sedrac c'était est-ce que
c'est sain ou pas sain d'avoir quatre
accords gagnés qui vont être un peu
concurrents alors
vous savez
la concurrence à ces grandeurs et ses
vicissitudes partout
la concurrence bon c'est bien que les
écorchés que concurrents qui vont
peut-être gérer chacun avec des idées
innovantes parce que innovante parce que
derrière la collecte on a beaucoup parlé
au fond de la collecte des déchets du
bâtiment on a peut-être pas assez parlé
je n'ai moi même pas assez parlé de
Laval c'est-à-dire une fois qu'on a
collecté il faut essayer de réemployer
de recycler etc etc en matière de
recyclage on peut avoir plein d'idées
techniques et innovantes et donc on voit
bien que là une concurrence entre les
éco-organismes peut être saine bon
en revanche en revanche là où ça serait
pas ça c'est que les égorganismes chacun
des accords organismes évidemment ils
ont cherché dès qu'ils ont été agréés à
avoir le maximum de producteurs
adhérents voilà ils ont été on fait la
chasse au producteurs parce que c'est
des producteurs qui parlent leur
contribution vont permettre à les
organismes de prospérer et ils ont fait
on peut le dire on est entre nous enfin
si je puis dire
ils ont fait du dumping ils ont fait des
dumpings et ils ont fait une course à
l'échalote une course à l'échalote
dégressive sur leur tarifs des
co-constructions pour attirer pour
aspirer le maximum de producteurs un
seul des 4 coeurs organismes a refusé de
se engager dans dans cette course à
l'échalote et ça
n'a pas plu à l'état en plus ils n'ont
pas respecté la procédure pour pour
changer in extre pour le rendre plus bas
plus attractif
voilà et cette course à l'échalote c'est
un petit peu une sorte de concurrence
sauvage sauvage sur le tarif des échos
contributions et en plus
c'est pas tout à fait même correct
vis-à-vis des producteurs parce que
cette course à l'échalote fait
apparaître des tarifs très bas pour 2023
pour attirer le client si je puis dire
mais masque le fait masque le fait que
en 2024 les tarifs augmenteront
sensiblement donc même vis-à-vis des
producteurs la démarche n'était pas tout
à fait transparente alors même que
Monsieur Perrault au nom de la
Fédération française du bâtiment a
appelé à appeler et ça je suis
complètement d'accord avec lui au fait
que pour les producteurs il faut avoir
les tarifs le plus longtemps à l'avance
donc faire un tarif
dumping si je puis dire en 2023 en ne
laissant pas apparaître suffisamment
qu'en 2024 ça sera quand même une autre
affaire n'est pas tout à fait
transparent voilà
merci
Madame pauvre
je voulais répondre à madame la
Présidente
oui
tout à fait
moi je rebondirai sur le diagnostic
déchet
qui à mon sens ne porte pas le bon nom
et probablement il faudrait mieux
l'appeler le diagnostic ressources
en fait quand on parle d'un diagnostic
c'est bien que on part du postulat qu'on
a un bâtiment existant qui va falloir
soit réhabiliter soit malheureusement
démolir et donc réaliser un diagnostic
déchets ça veut dire que c'est au-delà
des bâtiments de 1000 m² me semble-t-il
et donc ça veut dire qu'on va faire un
constat de ce qui existe dans le
bâtiment et voilà et c'est vrai que si
on considère que ce qui existe dans le
bâtiment n'est plus un déchet mais une
ressource et bien là on change déjà la
manière dont on va voir les choses et je
trouve ça peut-être plus positif de
parler de ressources ce diagnostic
ressource en fait il devrait être
obligatoire dès lors qu'on a un bâtiment
à réhabiliter ou dont on n'a pas d'autre
solution que de le démolir
et ça voilà ça je pense que c'est une
des exigences qu'on pourrait se donner
c'est de le rendre obligatoire de
manière à ce qu'il soit fait
systématiquement et peut-être le
généraliser aussi à des bâtiments qui
font moins de 1000 mètres carrés
parce qu'au final voilà il y a enfin il
y a plein de bâti existants très
largement dont il faut
se préoccuper
sur la responsabilité élargie des
producteurs c'est déjà plus difficile
pour moi de prendre la parole sur ce
point ce qui est certain c'est que
l'enjeu c'est évidemment pas que ça se
termine dans la poche du maître
d'ouvrage enfin en tout cas que ce soit
pas le porte-monnaie du maître d'ouvrage
qui en soit impacté et malheureusement
une kiné c'est ce qui va probablement se
passer donc c'est vrai que nous en tant
qu'architecte prescripteur ben la
difficulté qu'on a déjà aujourd'hui face
à la hausse des matériaux si en plus on
a des taxes qui arrivent par dessus
voilà ça crée forcément une petite
angoisse pour tout le monde pour ceux
qui prescrivent pour ceux qui vont faire
nos entreprises nos artisans les
producteurs évidemment mais aussi
évidemment le contribuable à la fin quoi
c'est lui qui va tout prendre en fait
donc ça c'est peut-être une alerte et
[Musique]
enfin en troisième point sur la
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
peut-être que dans le cas d'une
démolition
finalement c'est le propriétaire est-ce
qu'il y a pas un moyen de levier sur le
fait de taxer le propriétaire sur
cette responsabilité justement du déchet
qui va être créé donc là on parle plus
du producteur mais de celui qui prend la
décision de la démolition
c'est une idée
monsieur le président
tout d'abord
à mettre en place aujourd'hui ça marche
mais ça marche je dirais pour le une
raison de marché est-ce que c'est de
plus en plus de monde et vis-à-vis de
mes ouvrages pour des démarches RSE etc
donc je pense que c'est le marché en
fait qui fait que ça va être demandé les
architectes l'analyse donc c'est quelque
chose qui est demandé systématiquement
maintenant aussi bien marché public que
privé c'est vrai plutôt sur les grosses
opérations plus d'une mètres carrés mais
donc aujourd'hui je pense a été long
mais c'est en train de se mettre en
place le deuxième point évoqué c'était
donc les l'annonce de Bruno Le Maire
donc lors des 24 heures du bâtiment la
semaine dernière donc on se félicite sur
le fait de report de 4 mois donc on peut
de la mise en application de la taxe le
seul problème pour les entrepreneurs
donc bien sûr c'est une bonne chose pour
nous par contre ils savent créer quand
même une certaine concurrence déloyale
puisque nous fournisseurs
pmauront pas cet éco contribution à
payer et puis si on se fournit chez un
maître d'ouvrage un fournisseur
important lui va la payer puisqu'il a
bien dit que c'était pour les pour les
PM
selon nos sources d'approvisionnement
pour la première année honnêtement comme
la livraison Verdier la taxe est
relativement faible donc il y a pas un
gros impact mais voilà mais ça permet
surtout également de mettre en place et
on va également si on est concerné comme
étant
émetteur sur le marché de mise en place
au système informatique etc donc ça va
être un peu long le troisième tour qui a
été abordé je pense le coup pour le
mettre d'ouvrage donc il faut bien
comprendre que dans cette en fait
aujourd'hui on paye la reprise de nos
déchets donc à terme ça devrait être
assez bien le but de l'arête on sait
qu'il va avoir une certaine délai mais
le but c'est qu'on paye plus nos déchets
en mettrillons correctement en face du
emploi donc logiquement à terme il y a
un petit passage un peu compliqué mais à
terme normalement il y aura pas de surco
c'est bien toute la volonté de l'arête à
part qu'il y aura des transferts de
charges parce qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui
la démolition
c'est énormément de déchets donc c'est
la contribuer beaucoup à l'arête alors
chers des produits neufs vous avez parlé
de l'acier ou de matériaux comme ça où
il y avait pas du tout de taxes puisque
même on nous paye pour reprendre nos
déchets aujourd'hui on va être taxer
donc on peut dire certaines sortes que
le 9 va payer va payer pour la
démolition donc mais au global sur la
filière globale le c'est bien le but
c'est que ça soit une reprise gratuite
autre point évoqué et ça nous c'est vrai
qu'on en souffre un petit peu c'est
cette concurrence entre éco-organismes
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'objectif c'est avant tout d'avoir le
maximum d'adhérents donc on envahit de
mails etc ce qui pose un problème
également parce que comme je l'ai dit
c'est encore parbré on sait toujours pas
une entreprise du bâtiment ça va être
considérées comme émetteur ou pas je
vous rappelle que c'est ce n'est pas
considéré comme éditeur sur le marché on
n'a pas à adhérer à mes organes ils sont
nous ensuite on va voir un maillage on
va remettre nos déchets avec des
conditions de tri et puis on aura une
reprise gratuite donc l'utilisateur
final n'a pas adhérer un écorianisme
uniquement c'est uniquement émetteur sur
le marché qui va faire ça mais
aujourd'hui que c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu n'importe quoi et surtout ça
reprend également le risque que j'avais
donné notre introduction c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'entre les
organismes il y a des prix très très
faibles en fait simplement pour aller
adhérer alors qu'on sait que dès l'année
prochaine c'est pour ça que c'est 9 mois
c'est important pour moi vous l'avez
rappelé d'ici l'année prochaine on va
voir des prix faut être multiplié par
quatre ou cinq donc je veux dire c'est
pas très sain aujourd'hui c'est venez
chez moi je suis pas cher et puis dans
un an on va des prix par 4 ou 5 ça c'est
un petit peu la réalité du marché et je
reviendrai mais on va pas faire un débat
ici sur l'émetteur sur le marché mais
pour bien comprendre vous vous parliez
de la conception du fabricant des des
artisans que nous sommes aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre lorsqu'on
fabrique un garde-corps
fabrique une fenêtre
aujourd'hui c'est bien nous on passe par
des gamis on passe pas par des produits
finis et donc c'est bien le gamis qui
met en place le produit qui va orienter
sur le fait qu'on peut le coller comme
vous l'avez évoqué donc aujourd'hui
c'est bien nos fournisseurs nous
aujourd'hui nous sommes simplement des
assembleurs mais aujourd'hui si vous
faites un garde-corps aluminium voilà
nous on est là pour assembler et poser
donc c'est pas nous je dirais qu'avons
la main à part sur une charpente voie
etc mais sur la plupart des matériaux
c'est pas nous qui avons la main sur la
manière de la fabriquer ce sont avant
tout nos gamis qui nous mettent des
produits et je pense que c'est vraiment
avec eux c'est eux qui doivent
travailler sur sur être plus fruga dans
leur production et adapter des nouveaux
modes et également on travaille ça on le
fait également mais j'insiste également
sur ce point là ce que je pense que
c'est important dans dans l'Ajax c'est
vraiment
tout de suite lorsqu'on fait un bâtiment
il en a travaillé en faire en commun qui
est fort voir comment ce bâtiment aura
une deuxième vie troisième vie comment
le réadapter et puis Cobra également
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet important
accompagné également vieillissement de
la population quelqu'un qui a investit à
40 ans comment déjà 60 70 ans va pouvoir
adapter son bâtiment pour qu'une durée
de vie et ça ça va également diminuer
les déchets etc mais tout ça je vais le
dire
certes on a notre modèle de la
conception mais on dépend quand même de
matériaux qu'on achète qui eux ont été
prévus que c'était juste pour un
débattre aujourd'hui mais c'était le
petit ce petit bémol sur ce cette encore
une fois
nous ce que l'on veut pour nos artisans
c'est pas le coup celui qui paye le coup
en amont ou qu'il le paye lui c'est
complètement transparent c'est vraiment
la charge administrative qui va se faire
et on est persuadé que ça va les
décourager si on sert le Bing
d'industriel comme dans d'autres
domaines le but c'est de les décourager
à continuer de de faire des assemblages
et d'acheter des produits finis on va
pas débattre ici je voulais insister sur
ce point je pense que j'ai répondu à vos
quatre à vos quatre demandes merci je
vais donner la parole à Stéphane Demilly
on va Didier mobelli
[Musique]
monsieur Gold et puis vous répondrez aux
trois questions merci monsieur le
Président j'aurais remercier les
intervenants et puis saluer mon ancien
collègue des Hauts de France Monsieur le
Président Vernier
j'avais plein de questions et vous avez
répondu dans vos interventions
respectives à certaines d'entre elles je
voudrais revenir sur le réemploi des
matériaux puisque c'est bien sûr une une
piste importante
les matériaux pesant 42 millions de
tonnes ces chiffres que moi j'avais
enregistré donc parents de déchets il y
a une étude récente de l'ADEME qui est
d'ailleurs confirmé parce qu'on peut
voir les uns et les autres dans nos
collectivités locales qui montrait que
les déchets étaient fréquemment présents
dans les dépôts sauvages présidents
Perrault vous en avez parlé dans votre
intervention et c'est bien que la loi
AGAiT que prévoit effectivement la mise
en place de cette filière de
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
pour assurer la gestion des déchets
c'est bien mais Martin de sidrail qui a
fait allusion également dans ses propos
il a fallu attendre le décret
d'application de pour que la filière
soit en vigueur c'était le 1er janvier
dernier après on a dû attendre le cahier
des charges qui a été soumis à
consultation publique par le ministère
et ça a été fait uniquement en mai
dernier ce qui a généré bien sûr du
retard et la filière n'a pas pu se
développer aussi rapidement que que nous
l'espérions donc ma première question
c'est pour le le président Perrault dans
le réseau maillet dans le président
Vernier a parlé est-ce qu'il y a des
régions où est-ce qu'il y a des filières
professionnelles qui sont
particulièrement sous dotés pour les
pour les points d'apport je me tourne
maintenant vers madame peaufiché pour
parler du toujours du réemploi des des
matériaux qui doit être soutenus en
amont mais également donc dans le dans
le présent pour remédier à la
raréfaction des matières premières et
répondre une fois de plus à un sujet qui
nous préoccupe ici dans la commission
qui est là la réduction des émissions de
CO2
le Centre Scientifique et Technique du
Bâtiment
identifie près de 30 filières de
produits réemployables quels sont selon
vous madame l'architecte les freins et
les leviers techniques au déploiement de
la filière de réutilisation des
matériaux du bâtiment
et pensez-vous que nous aurions dû aller
un peu plus loin dans la loi Jacques
merci chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président je dois vous
avouer que après vous avoir entendu je
suis pas complètement rassuré et un côté
surréaliste on est à un peu plus d'un
mois à peine de la mise en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2023 et encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes et vous employez beaucoup
de conditionnel
ça m'interpelle un peu et je pense
d'ailleurs qu'il aurait été utile
monsieur le président madame la
présidente du groupe d'études que nous
puissions avant la fin de l'année
également en complément entendre les
quatre écho-organismes peut-être
ensemble et puis également les services
de l'État la DGPR sur la mise en œuvre
de cette REP
moi ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que
on a j'ai saisi le ministre Béchu en
juillet dernier train d'un courrier les
échos organismes l'ont fait également à
leur niveau concernant la contribution
visible
qui a cours pour d'autres filières rap
je pense des trois œufs quand on achète
une machine à laver on a le montant qui
apparaît de l'écho contribution et
nous n'aurions pas cette
visibilité très claire sur la filière
bâtiment tout le monde s'y refuse et
nous n'avons pas de réponse donc moi je
pense que c'est un élément essentiel
pour éviter l'inflation
répercussion sur chaque montant pour
chaque opérateur qui pourrait conduire à
au final à avoir une contribution qui en
réalité au final serait facturé de toute
façon importante alors que à l'origine
ne représenterait pas le montant
réel donc moi je voudrais avoir votre
avis sur cette la mise en œuvre de cette
contribution visible
un dernier point sur qui concerne le
réemploi ou la réutilisation évidemment
les échos organismes alors d'ailleurs si
encore une concurrence que vous
qualifiez peut-être un peu sauvage entre
les écho-organismes c'est sans doute que
le cahier des charges
ne prenait pas en compte ces dimensions
et ne permettait pas d'encadrer donc la
responsabilité en revient sans doute à
ceux qui ont rédigé le cahier des
charges
concernant le réemploi
je voudrais simplement si tu as un
exemple
une belle entreprise vendéenne que je
connais bien les charpente brillants
viennent de démonter un bâtiment les
anciens locaux industriels d'Alstom à
Nantes pour réemployer plus de 100
tonnes de matériaux pour construire une
usine pour leur propre besoin donc c'est
possible ça existe et non pas attendu la
mise en oeuvre pour le mettre en place
et pour démontrer que c'était possible
donc je pense que ça c'est grandement
possible
il faut sans doute que les
éco-organismes qui travaillent bien sûr
sur l'éco-conception mais aussi les
filières en aval puissent
donner cette priorité je rappelle
simplement quand on quand on démarrait
un
projet dans le cadre d'une démarche
Haute Qualité Environnementale qui
existe encore moi j'ai été maire
longtemps à partir de 2001 tous les
projets de la collectivité dont j'avais
destiné était travaillé dans le cadre de
cette démarche de qualité
environnementale et parmi les 14 cibles
prioritaires la cible 1 c'était entre
autres les déchets avec le tri à la
source ça fait plus de 20 ans que ça
existe dans le bâtiment donc il y a à la
fois la volonté des élus locaux les
volontés des professionnels que ce soit
les architectes ou les les voilà tous
les professionnels du bâtiment donc
voilà les outils existent
chacun de les prendre en charge et je
pense que beaucoup n'ont pas attendu
enfin pas suffisamment à mon sens non
pas attendu la mise en œuvre de pour
pour enclencher ces démarches vertueuses
voilà ça fait beaucoup de
d'interrogations de questions et de
sujets mais je souhaitais le faire
merci
la parole est rigolote
aux intervenants pour les informations
apportées alors même si la filière n'est
pas encore structurée il existe déjà des
réglementations qui qui encourage le
recours à des matériaux issus de
réemploi réglementation qui devrait à
mon avis préparer justement la
structuration de la filière certaines
collectivités volontaristes à valeur
d'exemple s'engage on le rappelle
d'offres avec des clauses incitatives de
réemploi des matériaux issus de chantier
alors ma question est très simple est-ce
que c'est un dispositif qui est
largement utilisé j'ai un peu la réponse
et est-ce que c'est un dispositif qui
connaît une dynamique particulière
aujourd'hui avec la pénurie ou le prix
de certains matériaux
[Musique]
je vais donner la parole à Martine
filleul
[Musique]
ton salut entrez chaleureusement
monsieur le Président Vernier avec qui
j'ai eu également le plaisir de
travailler dans une autre vie oui assez
lointaine malheureusement pour nous je
voulais poser une question plus
directement à Madame pauficher à
Monsieur Perrault au sujet de l'amour de
l'amour puisque tous les deux quelque
part vous êtes en relation avec pour
l'un les écoles d'architecture avec
l'autre
les formations d'apprentis je voulais
savoir si la formation avait
pris en compte les messages vertueux que
vous venez d'évoquer comme par exemple
la réhabilitation l'éco-conception mais
également la démontabilité car dans mes
vies antérieures j'ai toujours été
frappée par le décalage qui pouvait
exister entre les lois les normes et ce
qui se passe dans la formation si je
prends l'exemple des architectes ils
sont encore aujourd'hui élevé ou
peut-être un peu moins mais à la culture
du béton est assez peu à la
réhabilitation qui représente une
véritable révolution dans le métier
d'architecte puisqu'il ne s'agit plus de
construire de la même manière et donc je
voulais savoir comment
concrètement cette enseignements avaient
pu changer est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire quelques mots et peut-être aussi
une question à Monsieur Vernier aussi
vous avez vous n'avez à aucun moment
mentionner l'amiante qui pourtant
est encore fort présente est-ce que vous
considérez que c'est un sujet qui a été
complètement résolu le sujet de
l'amiante
si je vous propose de répondre à mes
collègues qui veut commencer
monsieur le Président oui je vais
peut-être répondre tout de suite à
Martine filleul sur sur l'amiante
je n'ai pas mentionné tout à l'heure
mais ça avait été un débat d'ailleurs
les textes sur la filière repeup
bâtiment inclut les déchets dangereux et
donc et donc l'amiante et en
l'occurrence et en l'occurrence les
déchets d'amiante qui pourraient être
accueillis dans les collectivités
publiques parce que certaines
collectivités locales accueillent les
déchets amusants des petits artisans etc
et donc là la fédérales est directement
en charge de ces déchets amiés qui se
retrouveraient dans les déchetteries
publiques voilà sur le réemploi on en a
beaucoup parlé
la
plupart des filières REP maintenant fixe
un objectif de réemploi parce que c'est
vraiment effectivement pas seulement
dans la même bâtiment mais partout on
essaye de réemployer voilà la différence
entre le réemploi et le recyclage je
vous le rappelle c'est que dans
l'oriente l'objet l'objet lui-même par
exemple une menuiserie redevient
menuiserie tandis que dans le recyclage
on recycle les matériaux on va recycler
le bois le vert le Plessis le plastique
etc bon c'est pas facile le rôle de
poids parce qu'il faut quand même que
l'objet soit suffisamment intègre encore
pour être réemployé bon c'est la raison
pour laquelle peut-être les objectifs de
réemploi reste assez faible dans la
l'objectif de l'emploi au terme de
l'agrément actuel l'agrément est
prononcé pour 6 ans pour 6 ans il n'est
que de 5% vous voyez c'est ça montre
quand même que c'est difficile parce que
réemployer un objet intègre c'est pas
facile donc l'objectif est de 5% mais on
a partout quand même des objectifs de
l'emploi maintenant dans toutes les
filières REP avant la loi Haget ça
n'existait pas il y avait pas d'objectif
pas de
et la dernière chose bon
sénateur je vais vous demander pardon de
de ce que je vais dire à l'avance
à titre personnel je ne suis pas
partisan de ce qu'on appelle la
contribution visible la contribution
visible vous avez raison elle existe
pour deux filières actuellement elle
existe pour les déchets électriques et
pour les meubles et pour les meubles
et et elle a été
reconduite si je puis dire par la loi
alors la contribution visible
c'est en fait la possibilité pour les
producteurs qui donc ils payent leur
écho contribution mais en fait il paye
mais après il transmette c'est à dire
que
c'est pas grave vous avez payé mais de
toute façon vous pouvez facturer ça un
peu comme la TVA quoi vous pouvez
facturer ça au suivant puis au suivant
pôle suivant et finalement ça se
retrouve après avoir été transmis voilà
du producteur au grossiste du grossiste
au détaillant ça se retrouve sur la
facture de consommateur
de manière invisible
d'accord alors
à titre personnel excusez-moi
je suis pas partisan de ça parce que
vous avez quand même des producteurs le
monde des producteurs c'est pas monsieur
Ferro qui me
perroquetera il est très divers vous
avez des producteurs qui sont quand même
dans le confort etc d'autres qui sont
plus serrés bon
ceux qui sont dans le confort financier
etc c'est la responsabilité des
producteurs excusez-moi et
personnellement je vois pas pourquoi
on va exiger que ce producteur dont
c'est la responsabilité à qui on demande
à lui de payer la contribution pourquoi
on va l'obliger à reporter cette charge
sur sur le consommateur sur les mois moi
je crois que dans dans
la transmission consommateurs c'est un
peu la déresponsabilisation du
producteur puisque à la limite un
producteur pour dire toute façon je peux
transmettre mon écho contribution au
consommateur final donc on définitive
bon je ne suis plus responsable
je vois pas pourquoi je me lancerai dans
les co-conception de mes produits
puisque de toute façon c'est pas moi qui
paye bon donc voyez excusez-moi mais
vous avez lancé le débat monsieur le
Center donc il y a des marques nous vous
excusez pas
j'ai mon opinion vous avez la vôtre et
moi moi je pense que quoi quoi qu'il en
soit c'est toujours le consommateur ou
l'usager qui paye et donc quand on
l'intègre une charge supplémentaire un
producteur il la répercute sinon il
rogne sur sa marge donc je pense que
c'est systématique et c'est vrai dans
tous les domaines dans celui-ci comme
dans d'autres et l'avantage de la
contribution visible désolé de reprendre
la parole si ils ont mis autorise mais
c'est que au moins c'est transparent et
qui peut pas y avoir parce que quand
vous intégrez une charge pour la
répercuter suivant et le suivant la
répercut au suivant sans transparence et
bien à chaque fois on y rajoute une
petite marge un petit bout de TVA etc
etc et au final la contribution payée
par le consommateur et largement
supérieur à l'origine et et c'est faire
un mauvais procès à mon sens ou un
procès d'intention au producteurs de
considérer que le fait de payer une
contribution qui serait visible le
dédouanerait ou le déresponsabiliserait
je vais commencer par répondre à Madame
sur la question de la formation
je suis par ailleurs enseignante en
école d'architecture ça tombe bien parce
que je peux témoigner de ce que j'ai
fait déjà la semaine dernière et du coup
que je vais donner demain
en cinquième année donc effectivement
ces notions de
de nouvelles manières de voir
l'architecture plus comme uniquement de
la construction neuve mais bien comme la
réhabilitation l'extension travailler
sur l'existant et même la rénovation
énergétique aujourd'hui sont des sujets
évidemment que nous abordons avec les
étudiants
alors c'est pas toujours évident
d'avoir une répercussion chez eux et
donc en effet tout le volet écologique
responsabilité demande un peu de temps
et de pédagogie pour bien les
sensibiliser à cette question là et
j'avais un étudiant qui en ayant
présenté toute les différents types de
constructions biosourcées géosées de la
structure bois tout simplement m'a posé
la question de savoir si il fallait
attendre que ces méthodes soient bien
mises en place pour pouvoir s'y mettre
évidemment je lui ai répondu non si on
attend tout le monde si tout le monde
s'attend on y arrivera jamais donc en
effet il faut y aller il faut être
conscient qu'il y a des pionniers et
qu'il faut les suivre et que toutes ces
méthodes et cette manière de faire de
l'architecture de concevoir différemment
en ayant conscience de l'environnement
de ce qui existe déjà du contexte et de
limiter les systèmes en fait de nous
rendre plus autonome évidemment ça doit
être intégré dans les écoles
d'architecture ça allait sûrement pas
assez mais en tout cas c'est en train
d'arriver en effet sur les bancs de
l'école et donc à ce titre dans notre
dans notre dans notre plaidoyer et dans
nos réflexions on a évidemment parlé de
la formation
pour favoriser la formation et les
savoir-faire de nouvelles filières déjà
on peut sensibiliser dans les
enseignements secondaires sur
l'apprentissage de ces nouvelles
filières parce qu'on sait que bien
évidemment il faut
des personnes pour pouvoir fabriquer
concevoir mettre en œuvre et donc on a
déjà une sensibilisation à faire de nos
futurs artisans et compagnons
par ailleurs il faut évidemment financer
la formation des acteurs que ce soit
architectes artisans bureau d'études etc
simuler la R&D la recherche et
développement au sein des notamment des
agences d'architecture bien entendu ça
ça nous permet aussi d'aller vers des
manières d'innover
et puis enfin évidemment renforcer le
budget des écoles d'architecture pour
pouvoir intégrer ces notions de
nouvelles filières d'éco-construction et
de notions de matériaux biosourcés voilà
donc en tout cas je penserai à vous
demain quand je serai devant mes
étudiants
aussi être répondre aux différentes
questions tout d'abord la première sur
le maillage donc on voit bien pour le
réemploi aujourd'hui on part d'une
feuille
blanche on sait pas comment les
organismes vont s'organise ensuite
pendant l'emploi etc donc ça va répondre
également aux autres questions qui ont
été posées et notamment l'expérience
avec Roger Brion avec qui on est très en
avant donc la sidération en fait un des
gros problèmes du réemploi aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il faut qu'on prenne nous
notre destin en an les différentes
fiches qu'on fait par exemple sur
l'acier le problème du rempla
aujourd'hui vous avez parlé du bâtiment
démonter remonté il a vieilli les
caractéristiques intrinsèques du
matériau en termes de calcul ne sont
plus les mêmes et on a un problème
d'assurabilité donc ce qu'on est en
train de mettre en place c'est des
raisons on est en train d'organiser des
maillages d'entreprises de nos adhérents
de nos entreprises qui vont reprendre
apprendre Davant à nos entrepreneurs à
démonter correctement pour se réutiliser
ça
on a des formations fortes là dessus et
ensuite il va pouvoir requalifier
l'élément qu'on a démonté j'ai donné une
légende tout bête démonter à différents
sécurité c'est donc il faut qu'un labo
donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
mettre en place oui mais non à labo va
venir se matérielle il est OK avec telle
performance on va également on a
également en train de mettre des
plateformes pour éventuellement pouvoir
retravailler ce même matériau pour
donner des caractéristiques pour
l'améliorer et tout ça pour qu'en fait
pour pouvoir avoir une une assurémité
vous avez parlé des je rejoins
complètement on a beaucoup de mètres
d'ouvrage public mais privé également
qui commence à demander des forteaux de
remploi et en fait pourquoi on ne peut
pas parce qu'on il y a pas la surabilité
aujourd'hui donc on a beaucoup de
contact avec la QC et on doit se monter
en puissance pour que le matériel que
l'on va démonter puis cette remontée et
bien sûr et bien sûr avec toutes les
garanties parce que c'est comme moi
qu'au final
entrepreneur qui connaît les règles de
l'art donc voilà c'était un peu pour
répondre aux différentes aux différentes
questions
la deuxième sur la visible
donc nous on était plutôt favorable au
départ la visible simplement parce que
on sait qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même
une crise du logement qui s'annonce
enfin tout prix qu'on trouve des
toutes les méthodes pour pour baisser le
coup de la construction et c'est vrai
que le Ray le risque le risque c'est que
vous l'avez évoqué en achetant un
matériau le distributeur tout le monde
va faire ça marche dessus y compris
cette taxe et là c'est vraiment un
problème purement administratif c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a fait le test sur une
rénovation aujourd'hui l'entrepreneur
pour donner le coup
de la taxe sur un projet où il achetait
on a vu des matériaux peu de partout etc
en plus avec des en détail mais on a des
mesures simplifiées par exemple ce qui
est bien pour des petites PMA elles ont
une taxe sur leur chiffre d'affaires on
va pas les contexte donc pour ramener
tout ça sur l'ouvrage réellement fini on
a fait on a fait ça fait ça peut être
deux pages de contribution pour pouvoir
dire sur ces petites ouvrages voilà
quelle est ma visible quelle est la taxe
infectée à cet ouvrage donc on avait
plus on avait un vrai problème en fait
de transparence et le travail que ça
allait demander à l'entrepreneur pour
pour aller voir ouais on achète des
tôles il faut mettre ça ça donc c'était
plus une complexité de traçabilité de la
taxe intrinsèque à l'intérieur voilà
donc c'était plutôt ça mais en tous les
cas mais on a quand même obtenu je pense
que la plupart ne fournisseurs nous
mettrons quand même ça c'est des accords
de gras gré la plupart des fournisseurs
feront apparaître quand même la taxe la
taxe sera mis de manière à ce que
d'autres entrepreneur on la connaît et
puis ça répartir sur sur un des produits
ensuite concernant le concernant la
formation
donc on a deux on a deux sujets de
sujets majeurs avec nos CFA et nos LEP
où on est assez en retard c'est la
transformation numérique avec
aujourd'hui il faut à tout prix que que
nos apprentis puis déjà toucher au
numérique et vous rencontrer dans
l'entreprise et qui est pas un décalage
trop grand et bien sûr la transformation
énergétique donc aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui est en train d'être
mis en place c'est pas facile parce que
parce que les équipements de nolweppes
et CFA sont pas forcément et moi jour en
tous les cas ce qui est bien et ça je
pense que c'est les suppositive
aujourd'hui pour attirer des jeunes dans
nos entreprises c'est complètement
différent qu'il y a quelques années ils
sont hyper sensibles à la RSE au bien de
la planète etc on a mais c'est pas c'est
pas que des mots aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on a un pénurie énorme de mana pour
attirer les jeunes alors certes mais on
a complètement changé c'est nous qui les
c'est à nous de se vendre pour les faire
venir et là-dessus je peux vous dire que
sur la planète etc pour la plupart et ça
peut être étonnant pour des jeunes du
bâtiment etc mais la raison d'être de
nos jeunes ont complètement
donc je pense que là donc ça c'est quand
quelque chose de très positif et qui
nous permet d'attirer aussi bien sur le
numérique sur la transformation
ouais je pense que j'ai rien oublié
essayer de répondre aux différentes
questions
puis après ma présidente de Cédric
merci oui je voulais de rebondir sur la
santé des matériaux réemployés enfin
dans le bâtiment la santé dans le
bâtiment et notamment en ce qui
concernait les matériaux réemployés et
je rebondis là-dessus notamment parce
que vous avez parlé de l'amiante et
c'est vrai que dans le dans l'enjeu du
réemploi en effet l'objectif c'est de
prendre ces matières qui existent et qui
sont déjà là mais dans la construction
neuve ou en tout cas quand on achète un
matériau on a accès à une fiche qui
s'appelle la F2S la fiche de déclaration
environnementale et sanitaire qui nous
permet de connaître les caractéristiques
des différents matériaux employés quand
on prend quand on parle de réemploi en
fait cette FDES elle n'existe pas a
priori ou en tout cas le matériau a vécu
et donc du coup on n'a pas de référence
donc il y a cette question d'assurance
sur habilité que donc que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure sur la question de
la pérennité du matériau mais il y a
aussi la question de l'enjeu de la de
santé de ce matériau est-ce que le
matériau est sain ou pas il faut savoir
que les COV les composés organiques
volants peuvent émettre soit sur des
périodes courtes soit sur des périodes
très longues donc c'est pas parce que le
matériau est là depuis 20 ans qu'il
n'aimait plus et probablement que
aujourd'hui le matériau qu'on fabrique
est plus performant d'un point de vue de
la santé que celui qui a été fait il y a
20 ans donc il y a aussi une notion dans
les freins que je voulais soulever sur
la question de la santé qui est
difficilement
jaugeable et sur lequel il faudrait
probablement se pencher de manière très
importante parce qu'en effet la santé
dans le bâtiment est un enjeu primordial
parce que nous vivons tous dans nos
bâtiments et que du coup la santé est un
point évidemment essentiel
merci
j'étais un parlement privé
d'ailleurs qui pour certaines ne sont
pas complètement ce n'est pas du tout
une critique de ma part mais ça révèle
ça révèle bien la complexité du sujet
qui est ça a été rappelé par notre
collègue mandeli en effet puisque on
vous souvenez lorsque le Parlement a
promulgué lorsque la loi a été
promulguée
la mise en place de ces trappes c'était
au 1er janvier 2022 on l'a reporté d'un
an pour des questions aussi de
complexité de mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui
on a eu une annonce enfin récemment une
annonce de madame la Première ministre
parlant donc du 30 avril pour laisser
donc toutes ces articulation se mettre
encore mieux en place moi
personnellement je pense qu'il est temps
il est temps qu'on avance on comprend
bien qu'il y a encore des points sur
lesquels selon les secteurs selon vos
différentes je dirais
partie prenante il y a encore des choses
à articuler et à mettre en place mais il
me semble quand même que le sujet est
largement dégrossi et je pense que
maintenant on peut véritablement se
mettre en place j'entends monsieur
Perrault un certain nombre d'inquiétudes
que vous avez partagées avec nous c'est
normal c'est logique mais on va avancer
tous ensemble j'entends aussi le sujet
de la surabilité puisque effectivement
même pour les prescripteurs que sont par
exemple les architectes et les maîtres
d'oeuvre il y a un sujet d'assurance il
y a un sujet de savoir ce que la norme
nous autorise ou pas pour telle ou telle
prescription donc mais là aussi je crois
qu'on va pouvoir on va pouvoir trouver
des solutions et moi je retiens aussi
votre suggestion entre diagnostic
déchets diagnostic ressources parce que
la sémantique peut-être intéressante à
retenir ça envoie un message plutôt
positif que un message négatif donc on
peut se saisir je dis ça sous le
voilà avec l'accord de Jacques Vernier
je pense que
sémantique effectivement dont on peut se
saisir aussi et pour rebondir aussi sur
les suggestions par rapport au groupe
d'études économie circulaire oui on aura
d'autres auditions qui sont prévues mais
ce que je retiens surtout c'est
le suivi on va je pense avoir à se
reparler à retravailler ensemble de
manière à être sûre qu'entre maintenant
et la mise en place effective que tout
soit le mieux préparé possible donc moi
je vous remercie pour vos interventions
vos explications et puis je vous dis à
très vite
merci monsieur le Président donc
justement je voulais souhaiter d'abord
je vous remercie beaucoup évidemment
pour pour votre présence et puis votre
écoute de nos questions alors justement
moi je rebondis sur la question santé
puisque j'ai fait un rapport sur la
pollution plastique et lors de mes
déplacements et des nombreuses auditions
que j'ai pu faire je suis allée sur un
site de recyclage de fenêtres PVC pour
rencontrer le problème des additifs qui
sont dans les plastiques qui sont
interdits en cours de route parce que on
sait qu'ils sont relargués et on
constate des effets sur la santé donc
quelle est la comment
envisagez-vous cette problématique en
fait des des matériaux et notamment des
matériaux plastiques dont on découvre au
fur et à mesure qu'ils sont évidemment
dangereux pour notre santé et
l'environnement au fur et à mesure donc
dans les fenêtres PVC c'était du plomb
qui est maintenant interdit par l'Europe
ce qui le problème au recycleur de ses
fenêtres et qui et qui qui disait qu'il
ne pourrait plus les recycler la même
façon puisque celles qui recevaient
contenait du plomb je rappelle aussi que
dans les sols plastiques il y a des
talades qui sont relargués en permanence
dès le début de leur fabrication et
qu'un seul en plastique et rendu plus
souple par les salades qui contient et
puis en retenir beaucoup ce sont des
perturbateurs endocriniens et on en
installe encore maintenant donc comment
prend-on en compte cette réellement
cette question de santé alors que les
problèmes sont émergents et qu'on se
rend compte de plus en plus
qu'effectivement il nous faudra prêter
beaucoup plus attention à ces matériaux
là
qui veut répondre à main privé
on a tous répondu tous les trois à cette
question qui est fondamentale
c'est-à-dire que c'est vrai que que ce
soit leur emploi ou d'ailleurs le
recyclage d'un matériau qui est au fond
était autorisés naguère
jadis même parce que dans la
construction ça peut être jadis ça peut
être il y a 30 ans il y a 40 ans il y a
50 ans donc des matériaux qui avaient
été autorisés à l'époque avec des
additifs autorisés et interdit
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on voit bien
que le réemploi pour des questions
sanitaires ou même le recyclage le
recyclage peut être compliqué par la
présence de ces additifs dangereux voilà
et c'est et c'est pour les ronds c'est
sûr et même pour le recyclage un défi
technique que de faire en sorte que le
recyclage des matériaux puisse au
passage éliminer ces substances
dangereuses
[Musique]
oui peut-être pour rebondir encore une
fois sur la santé moi j'ai assisté
début novembre au CA a eu 14 un coloc
sur bâtir la santé durable et l'inviter
principale était Suzanne des houx que je
vous invite évidemment à auditionner ici
parce que elle sera vous en dire
davantage que moi mais en tout cas ce
que j'ai retenu finalement de cette
journée là c'est qu'en effet il fallait
être conscient
des émissions ou en tout cas de voilà
de la santé par rapport à ces matériaux
réemployés mais qu'on pouvait peut-être
quand même les réutiliser
cela dépendait de la manière dont on les
mettait en oeuvre c'est à dire que par
exemple une poutre qui contient des
éléments nocifs si elle est
coffret en fait elle n'est même plus et
donc du coup on sait utiliser quand même
ce matériau là donc il faut juste être
conscient de la caractéristique de
chacun des matériaux et du coup
envisager de quelle manière on va les
mettre en oeuvre et ça c'est
effectivement aussi notre travail en
tant qu'architecte de penser à ça à cela
bien et bien merci merci à vous trois
pour effectivement
les réponses que vous nous avez
apportées on voit bien que il y a des
choses de fait mais qui encore beaucoup
de choses à mettre en place et ça va
j'en suis persuadé éclairé les travaux
que mènent Martin décidera sur sur ces
sujets importants merci pour votre
participation et bonne journée